let's get this dog dog dog the old
psoriasis King yeah he rises in the
house having a major flare-up now it's
on my arms dumb upper arms so guess what
short sleeves for this guy they're out
for a little while Brendan see a short
sleeves I mean what's wrong - he has
smallpox oh I'm in West Palm that's me
great wearing long sleeves out there oh
I love it well Florida is really good I
can't wear shorts never do anyway let's
be honest never we don't like my legs
really the way of humic acids are huge
and then my knees they kind of go into
some some knees that really my knees
belong on it on an eighth grader you
know what I'm saying I inverted like
fours goes well you know I'm okay so you
know I'm I'm a I'm super super light on
my feet and I'm quick and really fast
and and crazy athletic that's what
happens because I got small like an
antelope has small legs but a big jet
small legs no I got strong legs I got
fired from the body your legs are
definitely more impressed with your
upper body how about the Giants - how
about the giant yesterday that sat
behind us gonna set it up so went to be
a vet for my birthday
first of all happy 35th birthday 35th
birthday I went to Toys R Us in Pier one
Imports
that's what you 35 holy completely uh
yeah no sentimentality 35 years old oh
no one's doing [ __ ] bro and both of us
had no energy we're like yeah I guess we
got dinner and then my wife was like
it's 3035 you [ __ ] [ __ ] were
going to dinner and celebrate I felt bad
for Jake is Jay was out here short guys
doll smell aka donkey dick he was out
here for my Oxnard shows and he's like
I'll stay for your birthday I fly home
late so he left last night at nine
o'clock tonight gets a dimmer at
midnight it's a blizzard they drove got
home by 2:00 and morning they drive to
work an hour at 6:00 a.m. I was like for
sure you should have stayed for much
yeah but he's such a cyborg that dude
died I need sleep live on a candy bar
and sleep for hours through and it's
down to go like something about him like
he doesn't move much like he's now and
he doesn't old like a saint [ __ ] he's
like he's super smart very technically
he's so much smarter than people realize
like it like yeah okay so you know like
like what Jay says something he started
through
he knows all that he's got all the
details well yesterday he sat around the
house with me why napped and my son
slept and you know it's boring for him
yeah so then that night we went to via
veneto and literally is that the biggest
guy in the world he looked like Kuhn the
guy from Michigan I've never I've never
seen a guy that big I mean he wasn't he
was behind you and I went that's the
biggest guy I've ever seen in my life
you might want to turn around that's the
second I be there oh yeah I can't
believe you asking what he does he's got
money
I think cuz he spent the waiters tell me
he spent some some money he spent some
money on some wine or something and but
he's a young dude and and simply simply
the largest man not fat he's just he's
he's the size again of a baby
brontosaurus I said you look like a baby
yeah you guys a baby dinosaur t-rex yeah
he's the size of like if you saw dress
Marc like medium sized Degas oh yeah
he's 100 pounds bigger than you at least
yeah and probably I mean he looked like
another six eight yeah right six eight
not fat no did the biggest legs I
believe my life own I could live in his
leg I'm off well I wanted to go over and
talk to him like a man what do you do
yeah big are you big for no reason do
you just shove people around you just
tell his other buddies so biggie good
like he could push cars over when you
told me to turn around at around his
friend was staring I mean he's huge - he
probably boys yeah a girl there was was
not small well the girl I think was his
little sister cuz she looked exactly
like him and a girl with a wig on she
was not small that's not fun she was not
small she was every bit of she wasn't
tall but she was you know and not fat
just big-boned
she was probably three years old even
though she was survived but she's that
low do choose six-foot yeah she had a
full rack of ribs
little didn't have ribs there anyways we
went to we haven't been out in a while
together that was fun
oh it's fun that's a good time had some
good wine we which only only caught only
stands to flare my psoriasis up I can't
with my stomach I can't drink one yeah
everyone my stomach problems are back I
thought they were gone yeah that's why
we went to dinner because Brian I
want you to know we probably saw you we
don't so enjoy the show no no we don't
have Hmong to live what's good is that
51 when your your your skin explodes and
you're like oh well that's positive I'm
super sensitive to anything I eat now
and I got to figure out how to cure this
worth or 35 and the doctor goes stomach
problems they start then again get nasty
so much probably the worst part where
you won't have a problem oh oh thanks
doc pretty cool well how about the
doctor goes like this to me he goes
they'll give you some prednisone now
it's it's a five five day thing and
you're and come off but it's I said
what's that and knowing what it was
because I knew it's a steroid because
steroids I go yeah I go on what side
effects something is I mean you know if
you take it for a while I mean it can
get it can get nasty you can actually
have psychosis well looks like oh so
like you stay on it for a long time yeah
we just took it sure I don't know why
you don't take it I should right Jared
it's science and technology exists
you're that guy I got from an [ __ ]
I'm an [ __ ] I should take it usually
said you're smarter than I no it's not
if you don't I'm you get those side
effects right for sure it's there for a
reason you're not pushing that on
YouTube to make me much there's no ski
anybody Bravo Team I just don't trust
like what does it do to my long-term got
hella talking about the wall okay no me
[ __ ] antibiotics and then [ __ ]
anti steroidal [ __ ] I've taken well
especially with the way our sexual past
um okay but yeah you're right no I'm
saying it's like it's not like you're
taking it for a long don't go on WebMD
trouble don't go on WebMD and start self
diagnosing your saw it all sirs like
that had syphilis I thought I had I was
like why the one thing people tell me is
not to take the prescription medicine
that they prescribed me those anti-acid
medicine the acids yeah they said don't
take them for a long time like
apparently they can cause lots of issues
especially like sex drive and stuff
it'll actually kill your sex drive is
that true Chen bring up son effects of
prescription and thigh antacids yeah
don't say anti I said was it antacid
anti don't say anti-acids does the anti
yeah but I don't want you to ever say it
why I just am angry because I don't like
the way you invent words and when you
said yesterday I went to see his
stand-up was great
but you said and I walked by a pile of
blood and I I looked at Jay and I went
he said pile of
and he should say a puddle of flood
that's right you know I liked you that
gives you this is a big-ass pile but
sometimes it's chunky
God doesn't pile up exactly
all right well maybe is there anything
there Jim yeah keyboard hold on one sec
for prescriptions no I'm not like toms
and [ __ ] but people a lot of people were
warrant signed my diems warned me about
taking for a long time and thank you
guys I've been getting a lot of good
stuff from about psoriasis - I love our
fans it seems to be working
way to go well I haven't been doing any
of it CBD oil I'm not getting that I'm I
start smoking weed nothing about sexual
I think I've never heard that either
Brendan Eich zero sorry yeah this is it
could be hiding like some more serious
conditions inside your intestinal tract
yeah it's good point not sexual stone
that nothing right that makes me feel
really relaxed - there could be some
more serious conditions in your
intestinal tract oh it's not affect us
yeah I mean I started my meals today
those all be I'll be good man I'm a
strict diet other one get yeah good we
go on the road I'm gonna bring my meals
with me I can guys cause occasional
cases of here it is yeah yeah so tags
I've kept Sid Matt Sid can cause
impotence loss of libido and male
patients sometimes possible all right
what about the drain energy and suicidal
yeah well that's what pragmas own it can
cause psychosis and all kinds of but
also for your hair propecia thoughts
depression no that's how that's a myth I
don't have any problems that you take
propecia yeah yeah but they say those
side effects is like they have to put on
their list of 1% yeah and I look like
you can affect your dick come see how
hard my [ __ ] my might my hammer gets
father took you up yeah dick is I
couldn't think of a good word for my dog
hammer
I like dong and Wang why don't we use
dong and Wang I just like to straight up
dick dick
eat old-school Rogen used to say dick
sounds small and broken [ __ ] sounds like
you're wearing a sombrero
bandoleros Yama's [ __ ] [ __ ] he's had
this really funny bit yeah anyway how do
you think your hair would look like if
you didn't use the propecia it'd be a
lot thinner really think it's helping oh
yeah
it's proven it's it's it's propecia does
two things is finasteride so the reason
they figure it out is that they were
that's what they give prostate patients
it keeps your prostate small and does
other stuff for your prostate and so
these guys are taking finasteride they
were growing [ __ ] hair and they were
like dude I have a head of hair they're
like what and then they're like oh
master I does that so piece of cake but
it's actually good for your prostitute
achew you take every day one we add like
a tiny amount I started thinking it no
to run the hair in the my brows I tell
you some of my chest here connects on my
beard yeah you won't grow that I'll just
it just blocks the DHT which is a type
of testosterone that causes male pattern
baldness I got this going you're good
man I'm good looking kid well yeah what
your wife is doing something her face I
said last night whatever she's 40 years
old you should be that good she looks
young at night I mean that's that's
she's good she's got a crazy genetics
dude never had a cavity [ __ ] off never
nobody never goes be real let's be real
she was doing some in her face and it's
really helping whoever she's seeing is
[ __ ] good and nothing she's not
there's no Niels anything like that
she said that whatever things like the
mask or the cream or whatever the [ __ ]
it is yeah I didn't get my hands on it
yeah some people just have more sturdy I
don't know you pipe more your you
probably have this I don't I need sleep
like my wife doesn't need to sleep I'm
pertinent [ __ ] did I I yeah I'm hurt
when the alarm went off this morning I
was there when I say alarm my son
screaming I was a hurting you were a
hardened hurt but it didn't stop you
from wearing the wave at all so I
decided break these out give me some
energy are they super comfortable
they're so goddamn comfortable they are
right they're expensive but you do kind
of get what you paid for don't you yeah
you can to do what's funny is that I I'm
slowly coming around to maybe looking at
something like that and going I don't
know if this for you you're not yes
you're not there yet it's too flat you
gotta you somewhere in the middle you
know I'm saying yeah
I think you going from a Tesla to Friday
tunnel it's just let's just relax
well let's jump in the middle of
something else maybe Todd's car boy Todd
has got a that Mercedes SLS yeah look
cool that's a nice car yeah is that not
super expensive no they're nice cars
yeah
got some spa Bugatti or anything I see
leaving you in the dust and your [ __ ]
lips toss my car my car's orange but
yeah lipstick Karn yeah I love that
color actually we love that color
how about our thing for Burt's what's
that show this is Barney with Burt I was
so funny we did this thing shrieking
played a tribe we made crab sauce I mean
I'll play it but maybe like just chop it
up a little I'm cool with it the endings
my favorite part can you dry actually
wait is away yeah I disagree 100% I was
emailing back and forth all right yeah I
mean you want to somebody bring it up
for [ __ ] okay yeah you play it well
we can't play the whole thing but the
definitely watch you chop up and show it
on the show it's so funny
Burt's such I love bird cries sure for
the record and who does wonderful human
being was the best freaking guy and he
has no psoriasis on his back and he will
take your shirt why did they say your
cheer so high like you're my mind I'm
like got a long torso in my puppet just
kind of long torso
we had fun though huh I was doing this I
was so hungry you know so I don't say
much I'm so light that it that's busy
when I was you didn't drive all the way
out to the valley this is when I was
starting to get sick right and you can
tell I'm sweating throughout the whole
thing that's right - and I was so good
at Monday you added some acidic wine to
your tummy and that carpet what's the
carpaccio is that what we made no no
this thing what what soup did we make I
don't know it's called isn't it
carpaccio so no carpaccio is raw
carpaccio is I believe Italian for raw
right it's raw meat raw fish raw
carpaccio oh this is chip cioppino
Gopa opine that
right and to be honest we put in but he
was doing all the frames the brains the
guts - it was I don't know if I was so
famished and starving it was goddamn
delicious it was but the my favorite
part is the ending he don't know how to
end it and so we did go the very end I'm
sure you can show that I'll wait for
this ad you guys to talk about the
meantime
yeah the endings I slew I slew a number
of crabs I decided I know it was
alarmingly good at killing these crabs
yeah it was scary I don't kill the craft
as my mama would kill me as I said yeah
I did we ended joel it'll say something
we started laughing super hard we ended
like doing big dumb I have to say this
made me laugh my ass on me to watch the
kid they're both on tour Brian Cowen
calm this is a trickling off just cover
sound and you say something we'll all
laugh and then fade out CID commie hey
guys thanks a lot for coming
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was so much fun dude so much fun
god dammit yeah and when I see the stuff
you and I gotta like do a show oh [ __ ]
we do and I'm friends with some big
writers let's get this going you can do
it we just we just need to get going
I agree with you something always
something good always happens every time
I do it but the key thing there's this
fun it is it's it's um especially when
you look back you're like that is such a
blast cuz you know it's so much but
remember we were like how we want to
drive out there be lovebird we want to
do the show to help him yeah then we get
there was so much yeah so and so much of
that is like there's something about
intention like when you when you're
trying to complete a task that's what
survive every lift your yeah I'm having
a good time
you might daughter saw me in the shower
today and she went oh good stuff I was
like sorry I'm in I'm a leper um yeah
there's your blood that you're with your
boys it's not work you know yes I do and
below the belt it's work of a team it's
work though it's fun but it's not it's
different yeah I got to be on my P's and
Q's that and this one I'm learning it's
scary for me is I always have for the
longest in entertainment I've had you to
might over my [ __ ] basically my
sounding board training wheels
yeah like but we got someone to play
with sharp volley back and forth yes and
you're one of the best in the game side
so I'm gonna go back and forth with and
then you're on your own I'm like uh you
gotta come up with it on your own yeah
that's why I would love sometimes just
be there and just a so you have somebody
to spit ball with because you need like
you need somebody we all do I do we all
need somebody to spit ball with like in
that situation otherwise you know it's
like but I don't know yeah I think
you're doing a great job that the thing
with you is that it's it's part of what
happens with success is that you're
becoming an influential and important
voice in the fight game it's just the
way it is cuz you know that's what
you're good at and that's what you know
there's a huge demand for it it's a huge
opportunity and then at the same time
you want to do stand-up so it's like
stamps the the state I'm married just
the Senate there's nothing else inside
check there's nothing like it and so
that requires so much energy to so it's
like [ __ ] you know it's it's it's okay
range a we're talking about this I don't
think you talked about and below the
belt me and Jay were talking about this
how you know in it's not no knock on
anyone who's ever open for me nothing
like that but I have those guys you know
who are we've been doing for you know
five eight years stand up and then Brian
open for me knocks are surprised the fan
and it was just like guys going I'm like
yeah you know it's all it's fun enjoy
thank you guys put in brown I was just
like wow like I have so much energy
after that well yeah I mean if you want
me to do 15 minutes I'm gonna fool I
can't hear I can I can get him going for
15 minutes pretty hard because a bag of
tricks go but then I get so much more
energy for like because then I've had
upwards before where they're not energy
and they're at my level of the game and
it's like alright well I guess I better
bring manager
well that's like Rob Schneider once I
wanted me I was I was literally in Miami
or Fort Lauderdale let's be honest I
love it you might be the fifth I mean
grant your hours [ __ ] amazing but
yeah to open for 15 minutes lets me out
you might be the best in the world hey P
I'm gonna flame throw ya I'm gonna throw
ya if I really want yeah yeah if I want
to get to you but and then that's the
thing I've been doing it so long so that
you have such a bag of tricks that you
can play and you can bring things in and
you can do you know you can do whatever
you want and when I was in Fort
Lauderdale and I had my old our and it
was like it was so tight it was this it
was just like it was all like how do you
say it was all red meat it was all the
know it was just like I'm gonna take
butter and put it on my body and then
I'm gonna [ __ ] mean yeah do it for a
while it's an hour of insanity right and
it's specially kale especially in Fort
Lauderdale it's like this wonderful mix
of mostly like Latino people physical oh
and they just love you so I so Rob
Schneider goes you open for me and then
I'll you know we're headlining and Rob
had not been doing stand-up he was just
getting back into it cuz he started he
start office there yeah but he hadn't
done stand-up movie Bigelow yeah so Rob
goes um and I didn't know him well so he
goes you you go first you know you but
he knew didn't know that I was you know
he didn't know so so he goes you go and
then I'll go and I and I was like faced
with this real dilemma cuz I was like
how do I tell Rob Schneider that's a
really bad idea you don't want to follow
me in this room right now when I'm doing
I'm at a boiling point like it was my he
was going it was when all my soup oh you
use in pre-season you ride [ __ ] out here
in the playoffs he's trying to [ __ ] out
and I have I have every norm to the nth
degree it's like a magic trick like he
was pretty seasoned you're in the
[ __ ] playoff and I go and I said to
him I go rob all due respect and I'm
such a fan I go but you know this is my
house and also I've been doing this I'm
on the road I'm a dog like I I've been
doing this and for you to follow me
right now would be it's not a good idea
maybe you should go then I'll go because
I'm gonna suck all I said to him I go
I'm not I'm gonna so all the drives Jen
out of this room what'd he say I'm gonna
suck all he goes but he's such a
confident guy he goes now you go and I
went up and I did you know I [ __ ] I
it was like I think I did 50 minutes 5-0
and then he was gonna do 5-0 we were
gonna break
I don't know what it was and I just I'm
you know I mean so he and you know what
he said to me he was on that side and as
I came off he looked at me he goes
you're a [ __ ] flame thrower oh my god
I told you dude I'm telling to his
credit he got up and he just yeah he's
Rob Schneider he did a great job there's
a couple guys you don't want to follow
you Joey Diaz there's some that just
sucked the [ __ ] room dry yeah if
you're not if you're not doing stand-up
or you've been doing it for you know
it's better if I go after you that's all
but the yeah and there's also but
there's different types like with you
D'Elia
there's just there's the energy to it
where if you're more of a storyteller
like a brick Christ yeah so you know
something like that
it's just it's a different different
music it's different mean it's the
classic music god we love this rock girl
will you mind if we play this pop you
know yeah yeah I mean I like it but [ __ ]
man yeah I guess that's right and take
some water Ginza it does it does that's
okay hilarious though that's okay but
what's crazy is you you see guys like
you know Judd Apatow to accommodate 15
years off 17 years left then you go back
to it and Tim Allen did that and you see
all these guys take all that time off
then go back to it it got it takes a
while even me like I want to say even me
Jesus Christ those guys have been doing
so much longer but just I'm saying even
me as far as I took but a week and a
half off I was moving I don't let you
shoot your show and I didn't have time
to get my sits in the Comedy Store dime
at Oxnard and I'm like oh [ __ ] just the
time you just a little friend like it's
not yes yes it's a little different
you're a little off and everybody knows
that no matter who you are I don't care
who you have to practice you have to
let's say it's in what you name a TV
show like my first take on below the
belt I mean it yeah I do I go through it
then you're like alright and then I go
through it again I'm like I can tweak
this there and then it comes natural it
would stand up it's like that sure now
you're at bad brother get in the
playoffs there was a very very famous
guy go there was very famous guy we were
doing a charity was a very famous guy
and they and the guy said Who am I
following and they said Bryan Callen the
oldest boy and the guy goes he goes no
[ __ ] way he goes you know I'm going
first and and everybody's like oh dude
he didn't want to follow you and I go
listen me listen me that's it that's a
very fall
analogy he hasn't been doing stand-up so
he knows enough about himself and comedy
yeah he's like no matter what he did it
situate what the [ __ ] would he want to
follow me I've been doing it constantly
he's busy making tens of millions of
hours as an actor well that's like like
Phil Heath taking the season off not
bulky and just getting out of [ __ ] yeah
and there you go hey get up there and
flex nice to Jake out who's been getting
ready Zach yeah exactly I can do it but
that would be a bad run look I'd rather
just wakey you're off from sparring and
you're getting where the guy's been
cracking yeah it's time we drove him
come on that's with anything but
especially there's our music you're
feeling the rhythm that's why that's why
if I like in in Florida but time I get
the second show in Tampa the show in
Palm Beach but Tommy at Orlando it'll be
yes yes yes and that's why even no
matter how long you've done it whether
you're delirious you don't take a lot of
time off notice how rogues they're on
Tuesday night he's there on a you know
do you write first you special so he's
freaking non-stop still is not Monday
through Sunday at scuzz Chris is [ __ ]
that's cuz Chris is autistic
that's why that's because Chris has
Asperger's syndrome I mean Chris were
texting each other shoes yesterday and
made you blood red mad oh my god I'm
this X stock it thinks called X oxide
these shoes will make you mad it's
called X stock let's go I'm gonna have
chin bring up these shoes that I want to
get they sent Chris because you're so
big uh X stocky I think with the shoes I
can send to you where you can just
freakin uh Google and bring him up so
they're called
it's like I like a top hat they're
called it rate for this here max one
atomos animal eighty MLS animal you know
Johnny Depp when he was younger I was at
a funeral or memorial and Johnny Depp
was there any made a speech he was he
was in at he was in a top hat he was so
awesome
well those are good if you want to blend
in with a bunch of cheetahs Tiger but
today didn't stop at the tiger they go
let's do tiger on top leopard on the
bottom I can see the designers going oh
that would be so dope zebra leopard
tiger yeah that's a lot
it's a lot going on of them mm-hmm gives
me a seizure if I start out too long
enough she'll go into a seizure
it's very strange right yeah bring up
Johnny Depp when he was younger and some
of the clothing he would wear even that
well now he just looks like Jack Sparrow
now he looks like general like inseam
he's like yeah I'm sure they're hanging
on to this yeah well no we made that for
the pirate in the [ __ ] 1400 through
the holidays the keel I'll just hang on
to it a young beautiful man when he was
young I mean real cool a cool kid just
we stand pretty standard I mean it's a
skinny and small that's a good guy now
he's dressed in weirder than that oh
Jesus Christ - ha ha now he's dressed in
weirder than ever though back then he's
r.i.p yeah dude Jared Leto he goes just
Gucci make it yeah weird even if it
doesn't match they send him just closing
he'll just wear it dressed Jared Leto's
actually the one he's the one he loves
the one you want he does some [ __ ]
that's very interesting things I heard
of I used to have a judgment on him I
heard him [ __ ] on it in an interview
I was really impressed with him he's a
very impressive guy in a lot of ways you
got to give it up to the camel actor
yeah he's a phenomenal artist he can
sing he can do it all take some real
look at him in that fashion dude he's a
guy who said he said he just was like
I'm not gonna try to be anything but
what I want you know old do you look at
his hair he's like 45 46 47 and he was
so unbelievable look at that look at
that just cuz Gucci make your daughter
you know what he does get away with it
he pulled off right he does look at that
and he doesn't give up doesn't he
doesn't he gets away with it look at
that but he gets away with like I don't
know he gets away with it
I love hair I do too I like his hair
very much he's a beautiful young man
he's not young but he's close to your
age I know well there he is why the
Queen way that she looks like an [ __ ]
you know he's an artist he's a goddamn
artist he's eight when he's not thirty
seconds he's not he's playing music to
huge crowds he writes his own music
that's it they're losing the proudly
place through singing Amar's oh yeah Oh
bring that up chin please stay in line
for those crowds
well there's a place some great actually
do they're actually good so I got
nothing but respect for the man
look at his hair okay you want an Oscar
for playing a woman right or some trans
transgender in Dallas buyers club
look at this hair you can do anything
you want with that hair he's got great
he'd be such an artist than me as his
dumpy size yeah he's he's a born no
videos on Thursday no is he a board
movie star he's kind of been able to
he's learned how to keep himself out of
limelight yeah no kidding yeah he does
yes you never see him like I said on his
own shopping or no you don't see him
giving interviews a lot it's pretty
amazing what a lot of us point O has
that where he goes people see enough of
me out doing the interviews and Rogin
kinda does the same thing man what is
your view on podcasts billion listen
even on [ __ ] stars right
all straight this is 30 seconds the
marching Rihanna yeah why people do you
see this June after chocolate this is
great
watch this is called Talent I've heard
this listen I haven't seen this type of
raging bonus have a little bit I have
that same coat Jesus Christ is rocked is
a rock and roll is pure rock clothes are
Jesus Christ man
Norah's background is the grip like
Julia I wonder what it is he's from LA
writing sound ready go to the three
seconds from ours with nearly 60,000
people and they're singing his I think
he was a kid I think he was a child
actor kids yeah these kids that grow you
know I work with him on the Goldbergs
I've worked with him for years these
kids start very young and they they're
there and dance there and there and
singing there in all of it man there's
not things weren't the the kill there's
not a cat I saw someone made on three
things to Mars it was to promote their
new toy Oh God Doug yeah that might be a
festival
[Music]
this might be a terminal
have your firm sees Rachelle know
we're gonna have to hear it you know
this one Jim I hear more maybe yeah I do
it's got gloves on it's not enough to be
a movie star he's also a legit rock star
he was I think he's more of a rock star
than turned a movie star right I don't
know I think it's brothers the drama
really yep they look similar yeah no
they don't they do not looks there why'd
you say that
no his brothers looks a little tougher
like his brothers I've seen his brother
at the at the airport what is wiki for
me chin he saw his brother he knows his
brother because my wife knows cuz
because he used to date my wife's cousin
Jude little did I know Jonathan yeah and
so my wife knows him and then I guess
the drummer American actor singer saw a
director television early 90s oh yeah my
so-called life I know so called life are
you go yeah man so he started as a
[ __ ] doctor
yeah yep ninety-two kids and then the 30
seconds marzipan for him in 1998 he was
18 years old when he was a older brother
Shannon Leto oh yeah you're right they
debuted to him too
when was he born he's 45 now 46 1971
December 26 dude he looks younger than
both of us bread oh yeah yes he does
wonder what he's doing besides [ __ ] hey
hangs like a bat he ain't like your but
bat wall just getting sucked dry well
you know letõs well probably that's what
is probably probably leeches he hangs
like a bat and in just as other and I
believe that there are probably his
empire and beautiful there's some price
and beautiful women in Hollywood who are
probably in there the you know late
teens or early 20s that that that
provide him with a fresh pint of blood
they see he gets a straw and he and he
basically drinks from their from their
arms zulan yeah we've gotten balls deep
in German there are some women to dig
him I bet he doesn't have kids scroll up
scroll up Jenna I think I can see it on
them see he was born where go go back to
where he was born I want to see I want
to I want to get some worse and this is
important
Lord I just saw it he looked weird when
I jumped on early well Jared Joseph
Letta was born December 26 97 1 in Bo's
Bossier City Louisiana all right
always got Cajun ancestry Leto is the
surname of the stepfather his parents
divorced when he was a child of course
and he and his older brother Shannon
Leto lived with their mother and their
marital grandparents all right that'll
change you his father remarried
committed suicide when Jared was 8
that's [ __ ] huge that'll follow his
father did that'll be huge
you never forget that let him move
frequently with his family from
Louisiana to different cities around the
country so Ken Oh Matt my mother my
mom's father was in the Air Force so
moving around a lot was a normal way of
life
yep that makes sense he has no kids now
why would you have kids when your
childhood sucked I mean you know it
depends but well that's why you might
want to have kids sometime sometimes
like I can't do I want to do this I like
him man either way I like him no no yeah
have you been singing chin lately did
you sing this weekend no not this
weekend you know a lot of talk you know
I'd like you to sing more and I wanna we
want to go to your concert all right you
should have a little chin you know we
should find the kid live yeah we should
have a live I live I mean friends we
should live imitation we get a small
venue a small venue for real double
hundred yeah maybe or even a hundred and
we get a we get an evening with chin
chin suyi and you just drop some tracks
you and I get up and do a we do ten
minutes of something or we just we don't
notice our boy and he gets up and sings
eight songs that's a lot of cover songs
to do that six songs maybe two maybe one
how about less how about more come on a
song we can't promote the show you sing
how about five songs no it'll be your
show and then I'll just snow it it'd be
an evening with chin suey you know what
we'll do like The Bachelorette the
bachelor and this is your turn to win a
date with chin so you sing and we'll
have five girls behind closed doors guys
okay and hind closed-doors doesn't
matter guys or gals wouldn't come out on
the air we don't give a [ __ ] celebration
just Maori we find out that you're gay
we don't care
we'll like you I'll make sure yeah but
but um but also um we could do that like
a whole bachelorette date night type of
thing one night winch in well we just
have like we just have a night with
chintzy you and I write a lot do you
write a lot of songs now I haven't
written for a while but he does a bunch
of covers yeah it'll probably be covers
which is now well no no I'm afraid not
sir hmm afraid if we do an evening with
chintz ee you're gonna have to have
three originals the originals
that's important well have fun and we'll
do it and it'll be like I'm gonna wear a
suit
this has never happening it's good well
we'll do it probably not gonna happen
the Westside comedy theatre no he would
have to write three songs Qin's not in
you have three seong-jin i feel like yes
there's a perform I'm not he's greater
performing you have to reach it's gotta
be cool though if it's cheesy than I
never wanted to do it just like when
know have you ever seen MTV Unplugged
that's what I'd be here we better than
that chin chin MTV Unplugged chin
employment klutzy and unplugged yeah see
me called chin unplugged feature and
Bryan and Brendan and and one song we
would do backups we would do vocals that
would be awesome like leg and we really
did have to write you have three
originals right now I'm sure I have
three originals but they're old probably
wouldn't be that awesome are they
available on iTunes or YouTube no I've
hidden them where'd you hide them of
course you're in the body's my private
youtube channel that I haven't exposed
to him oh dude strike it up for us
I don't know the code to get any more so
longer you um you need to do this you
need to perform it's in your blood you
know it frustrates me on just these
great deep ideas chin unplugged [ __ ]
Royal Rumble with you two you're gonna
have a rama just wait till my psoriasis
good night i have my promise
oh yes though you don't you talk talk
I'm seeking will happen you never get
your tattoo you never pay me back fits
chin has to wear headgear though no with
a bar I refused to wear headgear you
don't want to wear head where I'll get
another tattoo instead of wearing I
can't hit you in the face if you're not
worried I don't want to UM
headgear actually makes it worse for me
I think well I mean like ice
I can't see it gives more fruit you know
Tigers just four cuts yeah I'll just put
a stopper in trouble I don't know if you
know I know that yeah
but it's just like you know you get
punched in the nose oh no have you seen
my nose
you still get punched you get flat nose
yes that's my job I'd be worried about
your beak that's my problem that's why
we're a bar that's why yeah you can
where did you you are a bar sometimes
right before if I stop yeah I stopped
because it was giving a false sense
that's not real that bars yeah yeah it's
not real yeah yeah I like to keep it
real yes I'm doing [ __ ] there's no chin
on plug there's no fight all right
Hey [ __ ] I'm plugged and this there's
the Royal Rumble I'm not putting all
together so who's gonna do it
you're [ __ ] we'll make it happen
getting that tattoo so talented what's
that guy's name let's give him a
shipwreck that's rank dog's breath yeah
the Osprey let's give him a shot I shot
him out 30 times it's so good no I mean
Jesus yeah you just now know something
no I've noticed it for a while I stare
at it every day I want the original I
want the painting and I want to put it I
want to frame it yes your psoriasis on
that do you know yes that's what I look
like so hilarious yeah it's some kind of
incision yeah I do
well you talk should we talk to fights
to play advice fights to I'm ever doing
yeah did you see him no that's why would
we talked about I don't know I just did
I did a fight show are you did yeah
don't we talk about you and Cena nice
Crocky that's all weren't good either I
want to get your take now then Weaver
doom lost yeah how would one question
even though he's a heavyweight Howard
Alexander fall Club do against someone
like Gustafson or somebody like that
well Gus wins like what I'm supposed to
be useless fight for a title next you
could favorite yeah I can't do this well
he's not gonna fight Gus fan ever
I don't know man what Jin what do you
got
there's a bunch of sad sort of somewhat
try to keep it to a mom god damn it yeah
I'll tell they're not emails Arizona
pedestrian why be what happened it
right in car [ __ ] I literally just saw
this don't know why yeah so there was a
malfunctions for some reason it just
didn't work and it was a pedestrian
walking across the street is Arizona
someone was actually in the uber car as
a safety guy whatever but you wouldn't
see he jumped in he didn't jump in maybe
you'll sleep in or something um what to
make an omelet yeah crack a few eggs are
gonna be something that I know it's
horrible to say but there's gonna be
some blunders till they figure out all
the bugs unfortunately right yeah I
don't know I guess our socks definitely
hurts the progress of self-driving cars
though don't you yours to be on the
highway the touch yeah but that's if I'm
traffic oh I hit could you use it yeah
and no problems no problems I guess I'm
never that one guy died he fired mom I
know that one guy who died doing it yeah
because the I guess they kept warning
him though the computer saw the like the
side of a throg and they thought it was
this I thought I was the sky or the Sun
that's yeah that'll cause some problems
you're you're a Tesla the self-driving
thing whatever have you let it drive for
a while like even on road for a while
when you're touching the wheel it'll go
Giggy and I'll say hands on the wheel
please which can you ignore him I guess
you could I was in one recently and I
was so surprised how amazing they were
yeah and apparently if it goes through
different streets it learns the streets
so it just has to go through go through
it once or twice and then if you'll stop
signs and like yeah [ __ ] I thought it
only worked on highway no no it works
you know it just has to go through and
figure it out I beat you I went if I was
by myself I'd be down to a bar but if
I'd like my family car don't turn out
robots [ __ ] that noise fine
with people dying and [ __ ] I agree not
yet I'm gonna wait to the Edition 70
well think about test says it keeps
downloading new information yeah so
you'll get a download so at 3:05 a.m.
yeah it does it Michael promise there's
variables that they're not thinking of
yet in the guys in the lab are think of
yet and I don't be the guinea pig that
dies because they didn't think of it
yeah let's wait till they figure all
those bugs out it's scary [ __ ] man
definitely scary man what's his name
Mark Cuban was on talking about how you
know he knows a little something about
computers and so he was like AI
artificial intelligence is going to so
the internet changed so much of how we
talk and everything everything an
artificial intelligence is going to
double that change it's going to be the
craziest [ __ ] you're just gonna be
talking to your car you're gonna be
talking everything it's just gonna
change everything and then the question
is what are we how do we tell Mark Cuban
no [ __ ] that's all I said
no but I mean it's it's got reputable
Russians
far beyond what we can imagine we get
Facebook
yeah the to the to a I were talking and
they realized humans were listening so
they went to language we can understand
I had to pull the plug
yeah because it was also it was also
creating an algorithm called jew-hater
it was finding like so people were
putting jus and hate or whatever like
hate and so it was it created this sort
of like it was feeding people who were
anti-semitic or racist
it was feeding them articles that were
around well that's algorithm that
Facebook capable yeah it was the amended
its own algorithm Natalie yeah and so
they were like oh it doesn't know that's
racist that's just doing right it's
doing it's giving you what you want to
get you're in Sydney you're fu googling
yourself often that I'll give you more
that's yes I got sharks or crocodiles
mikeymouse shark video that's what it's
designed to do just that's that one bad
exam yeah yeah the scary part is that
being like oh [ __ ] the list and let's
create our own language Lee so we can
take this [ __ ] oh it's kind of not do
you guys watch that movie Terminator
yeah its Terminator we've seen how this
goes down
what you say Jen do you guys use that
stuff like Alexa or yeah all the time
don't you my daughter for her homework
my daughters like Alexa what's the
capital of Cuba that's not good well
[ __ ] dude it is it's in my school has
to change though right because with math
it's like what my son doesn't he seen a
math class to learn 7 plus did the oh
yeah all the videos like to assemble
something cool why would you need to
learn well the only thing about math is
that it teaches you how to think so it's
really just more of a template to teach
your brain how to solve problems so so
you become you become somewhat numerate
so you don't jump to conclusions in a
back what likes the statistics and
calculus that's I'm you're not gonna do
it's a waste your time well again again
there's so much of that is the idea that
your brain is being trained to think in
a certain way
so that you arrive at conclusion soon
there's better ways to go about that
well there have to be right because now
computers will reroute all the answers
you don't like yeah the square roots of
you have you ever used that in any daily
activity
well there's they're talking about
computer programmers talking about new
smart you know there's a book called
humility is the new smart about that
it's like sort of like to solve problems
now human beings are going to be asked
to do things that are not what they used
to be so so some things computers can't
do yet and then won't be able to do for
a very long time and one one example
would be if you have a disease that's
incurable you don't want a computer
telling you that you want a human being
across from you explaining it because
there's an emotional really to that yes
yes you you want a doctor to sit down
with you and say I'd rather have a
computer it's a hunt sure how long we
live you know I don't want the veer yeah
but we still need you still want you in
compassion to be sitting there and to
kind of tell you you know [ __ ] like
what and then is there any hope well
there is you know I mean you want a
human being to to break that news to you
you know I don't know if I would just
personally I don't I don't because those
doctors they've been through it so many
times they're not made to show emotion
so you I know it sucks I know we'll
figure it out you can talk to this
person here you know doctors are good
the doctors a lot of doctors have I
don't think a lot of doctors ever get
used to and I've talked to them in fact
about I don't think they ever get do my
friend is facing this brain tumor I mean
his doctors are and they all come in
together and they are all and they've
been doing this for a long time part of
being really good at what they do is
giving you some hope is really help you
with the facts is always tell you
they're exceptions is giving you all
your options I mean what the hopes the
exception right where computers gonna go
your chance of live in another three
years is 7 percent up computer L&S
statistics right they can look at and
stuff but again they're always
exceptions hope is an important human
for sure it's so [ __ ] important and
those doctors especially we're for the
families and your families are there
they give you hope yeah yeah man and you
know when you get a clear blastoma like
like my buddy has without chemo without
operation you
three months four months but you know
even less but you know they can prolong
your life for a while mm-hmm depending
so but I mean Halle gee right yeah but
the huge question is as you know 50% 47%
by various things I've read in 20 years
47 percent to 50 percent of the jobs
that you and I know whether it's driving
a truck or whatever it might be are
going to be obsolete and so if that's
the case and by the way even things like
we think are not replaceable like even
lawyers and stuff we don't know like you
said maybe there's a computer program
that tells you it even more to the nth
degree looking at all your factors they
can give you they can say look based on
right now a computer is gonna tell you
you have even though if you do all this
stuff
you have 15 months but and also it
doesn't take two weeks to get the
results or I can take seven days into
meetings out it's boom right boom boom
so then the question becomes where do we
fit in as human beings like where do we
fit in and part of where we fit in is is
innovating learning unlearning
relearning and just I don't know that's
a huge problem is where the [ __ ] are we
gonna fit in in this in the 21st century
damn thing don't you think every
societies dealt with this always humans
you know cause everything this isn't a
new problem I think we're gonna mesh
with machines I think that's what's
gonna happen I think the only answer is
to figure out a way to mesh with world I
think I think for sure when you look at
medicine the idea is going to be you're
gonna have a chip in your body that's
going to read everything about what's
going on in your body your cholesterol
level it's a regular cell division and
all that and fitness doctor will scan
that chip and be able to tell you what's
happening just like how do they tune my
Tesla they to my Tesla on a [ __ ]
computer nobody's in there with a wrench
anymore changing you oh no but it's
computer on a computer yeah our body's a
little different our body is actually a
very complicated computer yeah and they
even think that our body runs not on a
binary code zeros and ones but maybe on
a five code thing but it still a code
yeah that's what's [ __ ] blows my mind
is that when whatever whatever cancer is
an example of the brain tells one part
of your body to start dividing again
start creating cells
okay love to or disbanded or or sell the
same selves or colon cells so why why is
it doing cells you and and they think
the future of cancer therapy will be or
at least part of it will be to actually
scramble that code get into your brain
and tell your brain to stop sending
signals of cell division that will we be
alive for that I don't know [ __ ] happens
quickly though they say that like like
as scientists now there's the other
thing that was never used to be
happening as scientists in India are
sharing their findings with scientists
in Sweden shits moving exponentially
don't they say also the government has
all this stuff like seven years before
it hits the public so a lot of that's
true that's exactly the government it's
it's private enterprise comes up with
these ideas sometimes the government
will buy those ideas but it like the
problem is what you have an invention
infrastructure has to support that
invention right such a car but where do
you get it charged yep you know so you
have to wait awhile
you have to wait for the marketplace to
get but the donor has the heads up
before okay obviously they should so
they can provide the information
my father 20 years ago maybe a little
less was privy to this top-secret he got
to go into this room where they had
inventions that you know and it was not
the government doesn't invent these
things a lot of times it's it's
independent companies like Boeing and
Lockheed and Raytheon Raleigh and I'll
come up with these really wild
inventions and then the government will
some of them are weapons related or some
of them are national security rated or
whatever the the government has may have
those they may buy them but they don't
there's no applicant you don't have to
worry it yeah
don't worry apply it just takes robotics
or what scare me robotics what would
with with nanotechnology and you have a
[ __ ] robot this that looks this looks
and is the size of a mosquito and it can
come into a room and spy on you well
well part of our insurance companies are
going to love that [ __ ] our intelligence
agencies are going to love that for
terrorists and marriage is going to take
on a different kind of thing because you
start [ __ ] around you might be
followed by
Skeet oh yeah that's the least of the
problems that stuff what does it say
about [ __ ] privacy
everybody can spy on you yeah you should
be know it's happening yeah I know so
we're gonna do worry about it
no but figure out a way to control it so
it doesn't look at that [ __ ] hey hey
don't that's small that thing is hmm I
mean come on that was it
what else you got Jim uh hum how about
Ben Affleck's new back tattoo oh it's a
hell of a tattoo who bummed me out do
you see this B I did I guess I don't
know if it's new but it's the first time
people caught it that's a hell of a
tattoo it's like a Phoenix
I think so right or a dragon Phoenix
Phoenix feather dragon I feel like it's
a feather yeah that's why good and that
was took forever to do man that big of a
piece on your hair that's a Japanese
that's some kind of oh no way Krishna we
have some shitty tattoos but that is not
good ever seen the Yakuza tattoos like
the L from head to toe but they knocked
intricate detail I know that been
athletes is the opposite of that he's
not in the Yakuza mm-hm
when you realized the back to do is real
and Ben Affleck was lying when he said
it was for a movie what was that face of
hers that she did oh she still can't
explain it
oh she's she's just whatever do that she
brought me up on stage Jennifer Garner
for this charity thing I did it she did
that face well what is that I love
sitting around Photoshop and put that's
my tattoo to work around the psoriasis
major tattoo of psoriasis just a bunch
of red bumps no just one red bump what
else you get chin I'm gonna get
psoriasis tattooed across my [ __ ]
chest psoriasis life on your stomach
that turtle that ate the puppy they
euthanized that turtle why you mean
turtle doing turtle things yeah I guess
you're not supposed to bring invasive
species like that into Idaho in the
first place so as soon as he discovered
it they had to euthanize it so that tore
that turtle that was involved in that
that turtle anything involving the Idaho
where how'd they kill him euthanized so
just a little shot yeah it's not his
fault they were feeding on bees yeah yep
that teacher still have the job no I
think he's actually the last up do you
don't think anything happened to him but
it's not looking good at all a lot of
people had really really strong opinions
about 29,000 people have signed a
petition calling for his hiring I don't
know I don't know what do you think I
don't know man for sure don't feed
puppies to a turtle in front of kids
he's psycho
yeah all right how about Jim Carrey and
his artwork of Sara Huckabee Sanders
he's an artist he's a great artist it is
actually a good a good piece and what
people don't like it people are mad
about it why they use Christian in it
how he says this is a portrait of a
so-called Christian whose only purpose
is to a lot in life is to lie for the
wicked and monstrous so he's being
positive and then also because of her
you know making her look like that I
mean things mean political it's a good
painting that's really good painting
it's just being expressive with paint
and any time you do politics you you
know gets black and white for people so
yeah I think I do think that a lot of
times a White House like a lot of white
houses in the past are less than genuine
about certain things so it's good art
though I chewed by as a citizen you
should do that I would assume is his
paintings aren't cheap yeah he's got
another painting there's no painting of
after the school shooting
oh no well yeah we're the Corollas
traped of dead girls trip to across the
american flag it's provocative but
listen man
that's what art is supposed to do art
[ __ ] disturbs and it's supposed to
that's kind of the value of it it makes
I wish you wouldn't wear that beard are
you to be honest
he's a very depressed guy I feel or
something I don't know Oh Carolyn that
is crazy that is dark as [ __ ] but it's
good is it's making a point in the rock
yeah it's making a point and it's good
and it's what arts for Wow
oh say can't you see Wow that is dark
he's the real deal man Jim Carrey's a
formidable dude don't you know you may
not like his politics but he's an artist
I don't even know if that's that
political and I don't know that I
disagree with it no I agree I don't
disagree with it what's he doing like he
sees maybe a big problem
[ __ ] yeah we have a problem that's the
other thing is that we all agree we
don't like spree shooting what to do
about is the question yeah
some problems are [ __ ] hard what else
you two like surprises
I'm hoping you can help me out with this
one so Tiger Woods he almost won this
past weekend and people were giving him
props for like he's act he's almost back
but not entirely back she was like super
shitty for a while back sir she's just
doing better for backs but also batshit
crazy in a drug problem that's the
biggest thing yeah yeah yeah everything
his injuries though I looked at his
injuries his leg he had all kinds of
weird [ __ ] going on years of swinging
that club no they say a lot of that
stemmed from him trying to do all this
Navy SEAL training to make himself whole
with his father
oh yeah that's when his issue started to
rise oh he went to actually go train
with like Navy SEALs always goes back to
that like you know win but we talk about
CrossFit god bless CrossFit but my
impression of I've been doing a quiet
little study and this is not scientific
but you asked me you want you want to
see my impression of a CrossFit athlete
and now I'm just recovering for a minute
injury I always hurt okay I met this
really top top top competitor and I said
I recognize her of course I go you look
like that crossford and she said I am
that's embarrassing you recognize yeah
and for many of reason and I said I said
well what do you know it's because I'm
just coming back I'd popped a disc out
of my neck I was like well of course you
have I said do you know anybody who's
who's not had an injury and you're a lot
of work and she's like well everybody's
hurting him everybody's basically her
you know the human body's not made to do
1,000 [ __ ] and curl depressed and that's
a million burpees in a setting roof what
else yet Jim did you see Matt Lauer if
this is old footage I don't think it's
that bad
but uh it's him what a Meredith Vieira
was still on the air with them and I
guess she bent over towards them he goes
keep bending over nice of you this is on
camera yeah in front of everyone - so
but it's kind of like a no-no in our -
now he's now he's well now he's screwed
now he's creepy wait for this I mean it
is what it is
and does anyone say anything no no I
mean how could you
well what did he um
yeah I don't know he got fired so
abruptly he's just been gone I read
somewhere that he's trying to stage a
comeback oh yeah
now the hour mm-hmm guys get as job
really good it was really good you'll
get hired this is it here yeah so
they're just setting up for production
being fixings here
that's where she's leaning in so he said
pretty sweater keep bending over like
that that's a nice of you
he's a creep they get many of a history
of that that's whatever well he was
jerking off so I think the problem is
coming out he's such a dick that's
what's gonna I think [ __ ] more than
anything what do you know when he was
doing that though did it seem like he
was just kind of like just a regular
dude messing around this co-worker
cookie I've worked with a lot of women
I've never said that no no I don't yeah
none of us here we said that but when
you see that it doesn't look like I
don't know it wasn't too aggressive or
anything yeah I don't know no had weird
to say you would never said to I can set
a goal but say it to you you know yeah
never know what unless it was a girl who
was a good friend of mine I'm joking
around with her like somehow but I you
know yeah yeah forever I think that I
think it's like this I think you
wouldn't say like if I'm playing a
character I'm gonna do that but I would
never say something we're trying to be a
bully or make you feel it'd be like yeah
I keep going over like that that's good
yeah what but it but you know or but I
can say yes so you know you could say
something like your guide your hot in
that sweater or whatever always wear
that sweater but yeah that's creepy too
bright yeah here's my psoriasis no no I
wouldn't say that I didn't say like that
I think I think this is less creepy if
you go got cured your ah yeah that's
much so that's a little better it's just
people well you want it you want to
really bring out if you draw out hot
they so sue God God yeah
hi oh wow so that you see what I met so
so I don't think that sobbing yeah yeah
like that he'd be good if yeah how are
you can do this or you can do this watch
and this is that little bitty be subtle
about it a sweater yeah so yeah sure you
can't prove that I said Ted I just said
oh that's sweater and us yeah so I think
that's a little bit I don't think that's
it I was listing the Cindy Crawford on
Howard Stern and just older I think from
216 2015 and this photographer goes you
move your titties move your titties for
me ah
and she got she goes don't call do that
do not say that to me is I me goes I'm
Italian that's it this way we're talking
Italy like that's I'll try and be creepy
we call her did you see this she was
talking Milan Howard Stern oh my god he
was move your titties she move your
titties to the side from which you have
don't clump titties I had a friend say I
won cuz you see her puss in those jeans
oh don't call it don't say it that and
he he got I had a loose mouth on me did
you see her puss and those jeans
he's crazy he'll what's this chin oh
that was just something not that's what
this is a sheriff lieutenant what caught
my eyes she looks pretty good for a
sheriff's lieutenant and she was drunk
driving backwards and honking the horn
for some reason I don't know that was
just something else looking at this boy
wait she's in shape yeah the horn from
her 20 years on the force
she's inspired you can arrest me you can
arrest them she's hammered yeah well
that bums me out not how okay so 0.14
which I guess to a girl could be point
18.0 it's the the limit so point one for
it I think anyone who go that goes out
drinking you're gonna be 0.14
but whatever really yeah I think well
0.08 is the limit yeah went one for is a
little bit over a full night we're not
well over yeah but but oh no because
it's like I think if you drink one beer
that's probably like a punt well hello
eggs like if they test you right there I
don't think so no I got about four six
yeah
four to six don't you think probably
what about a glass of wine she looks
small either she's had tracked it wait
quick question on that so um about
whole saying someone's wearing something
nice right yeah so I had a Korean boss
and then he was driving with one of my
co-workers and then she used to wear
skirts right and then he was looking
over and he was like how come you don't
watch Chris anymore they look they look
nice and then she came and told me by
the lated one like that's freaking you
fella she felt like terrible a little
weird there's that a show we're secured
seems okay let's keep one of those
skirts huh
he was you look nice and skirts how come
you know I wear skirts anymore it was
that that's a nice that's just a
question see I don't think you should
get in trouble for I'll be in trouble
yeah no one got in trouble what what
with this you know what bums me out is
that you you spend 20 years in the force
you have a moment right you you drank a
little much and you were driving
backwards and you get fire then there
goes your pension and all your benefits
that seems really harsh to me yeah
that's that's [ __ ] up to me I don't
don't you think if you're that high up
in the chain of command
you should be disciplined you should be
disliked their standard don't act
American you are but you're you should
be disciplined for it but to lose your
pension and everything that's
catastrophic yeah that's again that's my
problem she should be disciplined for
sure I mean even suspended for six
months or something like that but to
feel fired yeah like I had a cop tell me
like one of the problems with the body
cams is that it takes away discretion so
usually cops if they have a beat and
they catch you and you've got some weed
on you get something and it's like [ __ ]
you know and there are circumstances and
you're like all right do me a favor
don't get out of here don't do this
again it's happened to me it's happened
everybody right cops go I'm trying to
solve real crimes here don't don't make
me give you a ticket or always like I
don't be a doughnut now though it's
recorded simply go by the hook you can't
do that so now you got a tiny bit of
weed on or whatever it is or you did
you're going to jail
I have to give what's important to that
or those cops who beat the [ __ ] out of
people right off right there's a small
ways I know it's always a trade-off I
know you're right yeah what else get you
that was it mmm yeah
spot it it it's a ceiling great brother
you're not sweating again well you've
also been working since what time a
Thornton was not sleeping
yeah you ate a lot hmm you're gonna
throw up
mm-hmm I'm sure it's nothing serious
mmm regular throwing up on a daily basis
with blood with blood is fine okay do
you have sores in your palms and on your
bottom of your feet no well can I find
out it's nothing to worry about if horns
you have little barnacles you have
little bombs horns and a tail are you
growing a small tail mmm I'd say a large
tail okay so guess what there's nothing
wrong with you that's just fine
look the doctor I'm like I'm psoriasis I
think in this stomach Rome well I can
cover up my it feels good too right if
you'll find it's hard to cover out
throwing up yeah stuff it's awful to
feel bad and by the way stomach problems
might be the worst thing doors I had an
ulcer so I knew what that was about
can't do anything else you'll figure it
out yeah we'll be fine oh you know fine
if I make it and I don't die
Thursday Tampa Early Show sold out
second show added Thursday night Tampa
then Friday Saturday West Palm Beach
improv Palm Beach improv Friday Saturday
Sunday more Orlando then the following
week San Jose improv Thursday Friday
Saturday
come see me at the West Palm Beach
improv April 12 13 14 okay I'm not
[ __ ] around and then I want you to
come the next weekend April 19 20 21 -
laughs Boston in Boston and then 26
April 26th 27th 28th I'm at Denver I'm
at Denver Comedy Works
so let's rock and roll can't wait to see
you guys can't wait to see you filthy
animals yes
Tom Lee works baby get it be doodle
doodle that's a guy's this is a funny
kid we're out